but House Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi
says that voters should back Democrats
in November because it will help illegal
immigrants so vote for your Democrat
candidate and they'll let lots of people
in the country to take your jobs we are
not going to be able to get it done
under the Republican leadership in
Congress we believe that we will have
leverage when we win in November
leverage in November that's intended to
appeal to Hispanic voters but it may not
be working polls have shown president
Trump's approval with Hispanics to be
above 30% that's better than the vote
share he got in 2016 a virus Salazar is
a Republican who's running for Congress
in Florida and she joins us today Elvira
it we often think that in your state for
example Cuban Americans tend to vote
Republican but we're seeing signs that
actually there's a broader appeal among
the Hispanic population now well it is
indeed but I want to answer to what
Nancy Pelosi was saying and once again
the Democrats are trying to play
political football with Hispanics in
2008 in 2009 President Obama said to my
colleague from Univision Jorge Ramos
that we were going to have an
immigration reform law the first year of
his presidency in reality he used his
political capital to pass Obamacare so
right there the Democrats and Nancy
Pelosi had the wonderful and magnificent
opportunity to stop this immigration
reform problem that we have or to pass
an immigration reform law and in reality
what the Democrats gave us were Crump's
called the daca executive order yeah
into night and I want and I think that
that we should really point out and
these are facts this is not analysis
that in 1996 President Clinton signed
something called the immigration reform
law which gave the legal framework for
President Trump to be separating
families so let me just start with those
two facts that's why President Obama and
Nancy Pelosi are traitors to Hispanics
now why are Hispanic
now giving approval ratings because
Hispanics share many of the core values
that are dear to the debt too they have
Republicans we are god-fearing
law-abiding we like small government we
are so self-reliant we do not want
government our lives we fear God and we
want to we love this country let me and
let me just ask you a question on that
though el Elvira because the people can
have different views on that but what I
find interesting about the Democrats
view of Hispanics and the media's the
media assumed that lawful Hispanics in
the United States only care about
illegal immigration but in fact they're
just ethnic solid solid arity voters
that if you've been in this country for
generations and you're Hispanic your
most important issue is letting in lots
of other Hispanic illegals is that true
that that's the only issue you guys care
about now it is very important for us to
find a solution to both people that have
lived here for more than 15 20 years
like the TPS recipients we don't want
those people to be thrown out of your
like cattle because they have put roots
in this country that's why an
immigration reform law is so important
it's important for us but also the
economy look what's happening with the
economy right now that is benefiting
that's suddenly true we have to leave it
there
Elvira but thanks very much and good
luck in your race